thank you all for joining us on our talk
today in which you take you through a
deep dive of Google clouds
I am recommender and we will walk you
through how a bow was successful in
minimizing permissions using this
solution sonal and the uber team
provided us with valuable insights
during the early stages and they'll be
sharing who was joining and improving I
am for the cloud environment - ah Thank
You Abby hello everyone my name is sonal
and I am a security engineer at uber I'm
thrilled to be here today to talk about
how I am recommend helped us identify a
significant number of over granted
permissions in our GCP infrastructure
and help us bring closer to our goal of
achieving least privilege ok let's get
started so today we're going to talk a
lot about I am policies so let's first
start with a quick refresher for those
who might not be too familiar with an
anatomy of I am policy the policies are
shown here today are a list of bindings
of rules to members rules contain
permissions and it can be referenced
once in the policy members can include
groups users service accounts and more
here things can get a bit complex if the
group contains nested group as members
the policy also contains an audit config
that determines which permission tags
are logged the policy document is
attached or applied at a resource for
example it can be applied on a project
and then inherits downward all the
resources in that project so effective
access for a member is a combination of
their roles in this policy and a union
of all of those inherited from above
like from a folder now policy evaluation
always traverses the hierarchy tree
downward this is why in some cases
managing project level policies is
recommended lastly remember that setting
policy programmatically replaces any
existing policy on the resource so think
about it as a whole and not just a Delta
to avoid removing any old content that
was already there now assuming you
understand that well let's think about
whether your policies are constructed
accurately to reduce security risk
exposure ideally you want to reach a
state of least privilege where you limit
the attack surface by granting users
only the access or the permissions they
need but we found when it comes to risk
exposure people tend to underestimate
the risk they're in it's only human
nature and while digging into this
problem space with our customers we
found that consistently across the board
admins were granting way more
permissions than their users needed one
reason was to ensure that developers
could do what they want but also because
changing policies is complex and they
didn't want to break anything but this
exposes them to risk so we heard our
customers asked for tooling to
understand this risk and help them get
towards the state of least privilege
another big problem in the cloud is
human miss configuration so what was
needed was some advanced tools that
admins can turn on for the end users to
detect bad policies self diagnosis in a
way that goes a long way to give admins
a power to say it's not only up to the
individual project teams but I'm going
to check for these bad things as well so
if you're a security professional who's
concerned about this here is some
prescriptive guidance from Google on how
you should think about getting to least
privilege as with most things start with
the white first understand how much
access is provisioned across your
production workloads to initiate any
kind of policy cleanup you will first
need data that's compelling and based on
actual usage then tie that cleanup back
to organization goals like containing
insider risk which is one of the leading
causes of breaches and finds an aim
towards educating your project teams so
they are better aware of their risk
posture and their driving towards
cultural change then as you are ready to
start taking action create a face plan
that starts with reducing permissions
towards a safer baseline most customers
ought to do a quarterly access review
and then for high privileged roles like
owner and it
we recommend a higher cadence which
could be on a daily basis lastly you can
also prioritize based on the member so
you should pay attention to service
accounts maybe start there and to reduce
grants and service accounts and
especially look for service account
impersonation permissions if they are
not needed for individual members also
look for dormant users who might be
orphaned but present in your policies
and and lastly in terms of who does this
we feel in order for this to be
successful with the right tuning least
privilege should be the responsibility
of all project teams and not just
security professionals so here's where I
am recommender comes in it helps
security and non-security professionals
identify and remove unwanted access to
GCB by using machine learning to make
smart access control recommendations
right here in the IM page the
recommender is going to show you how
many permissions you have given and what
is actually being used there's no need
to collect and parse through access logs
we've done all that hard work for you
in the backend we store and process
petabytes of data on a daily basis all
of this is at no additional charge to
our customers we now simply show you
this information show you this
compelling data right next to the users
assigned role now it looks like most of
the users in my project hero are ok and
a few of them are using a lot less than
they were granted you will see here that
three light bulbs have popped up this is
where our ml models have found a
recommendation for a better fitting role
automatically in the background I had to
do no work the service account here on
the top row has the owner role with
about 1,800 permissions but it's only
using 31 out of them so here I am
recommended shows me that I must change
its role to reduce secured years now if
I'm interested in details I can double
click and get some more analysis behind
the recommendation so here the tool is
showing me that this service account
should be moved to the big query admin
role and why by highlighting the
permissions that are safe to remove in
it ml also picks up that this account
will need the saved queries update
permission in the future based on
similar usage patterns now this is a
permission it already has but it has not
used and you can find this marked with a
blue ml icon everywhere in the cloud
console so this helps make sure that
this user or account does not miss out
on permissions and don't need to come
back later to request more and now you
know latest update we've also added the
ability for you to customize a
recommendation so if you want to remove
a permission or add one you can do that
right here in the recommendation screen
in context which creates a custom role
and now this custom role will be based
on actual activity data and improved
with Google ml to suggest which
permissions you should add based on
observed patterns in the cloud so as a
user you just need to hit apply
to make the change and this custom role
gets created and now it should be
recommended to other users who have the
same similar need now
Oberon is taking some really innovative
steps with our recommendations and
they've integrated this into their
security of the mission pipeline so now
to take you through that journey so now
we'll have to understand what you've
done and with our recommendations
in GRB Boober has a tripod strategy for
infrastructure we maintain on premise
and we have a presence in AWS and GCP in
GCP we are about last skilled shop you
can see we have 90,000 roll bindings
alone aren't cloud security team is
responsible for security in AWS and GCP
our team's mission is to enable our
partner teams which are business teams
to conduct business as usual and
leverage cloud in a secure and efficient
way we are interested with functions
like inventory management asset
management roles granting and
provisioning in the cloud at uber we
would like builders to build with the
above functions in mind we would like to
strike a balance between our partner
teams and the security team and it is
hard to do because partner teams want
ease of allocating resources in the
cloud they want ease of maintaining
their resources and we want to encourage
ownership in them as a cloud team we
would like our eyes to be on a cloud
infrastructure we would like to
remediate over granted permissions and
overall maintain lease privilege and by
that I mean reduce our attack surface
and apply permissions as needed so let's
focus on over granted permissions
over-provisioning can lead to data
breaches for example an identity that
has high privilege role gets compromised
and is used to access PCI PII data this
is data with high level of data
classification as needed by compliance
this can lead to severe problems
it is a real-world example and we have
seen it before it is quite common asking
engineers to choose a more nuanced role
is confusing to them they often resort
in picking up editor or owner roles
because it gets the work done so then
what is our approach to release
privilege we would like to monitor a
footprint what are our cloud assets
our identities how many roles are for
those identities we have targeted use
cases in mind for example service
account with primitive roles which each
of these roles having more than 2500
permissions same for user accounts and
Google Groups then we have the orphaned
accounts for example a co-worker has
left the company and in ubers case the
account needs to be cleaned up in GCP
environment then there are the older
unused permissions these are not used by
anybody they are simply lying around
unacknowledged
you would like to clean them up with
this we have two solutions in mind one
is create a ticket for the partner teams
simply because we do not have enough
business context in the ticket will
provide enough information of why the
ticket is generated and how to go about
fixing it the second one is to auto
apply the recommendation by the security
team itself and it will be done in an
automated way so with the least
privilege in mind we would like our
recommendations to be data backed in our
experience with the previous cloud
provider we found that we had to
manually write scripts to find out the
activity log determine the access
pattern and then put the data into sheet
and then go through each of that data
manually and try to remediate the
recommendation it often leads to
problems like access denied because
there is no other intelligence to the
recommendation then simply the access
traffic enter GCP I'm recommender with
also the bells and whistles of being
based on historical activity logs and
being backed by ml wherein it predicts
if a role might be needed in near future
we do not have to pay for the logs
because I am recommended does all the
heavy lifting of collecting storing and
analyzing loss it is also API driven
which makes it possible to automate and
make it a repeatable process so what is
our solution this is a very high-level
overview of how we have automated I am
recommender the major components are
manager manager runs periodically to get
recommendations from the IM recommender
api it simplifies the recommendations to
be used internally and then stores it
into a database it then invokes an
action action is a rules-based engine it
determines what should be the
remediation step for the recommendation
and it also prioritizes because we have
hundreds of projects and we have
hundreds of recommendation for each of
those projects it was important for us
to prioritize the recommendation and
hence we introduced the concept of risk
scoring our risk scoring is based on two
steps first business rules we started
with the NIST framework and then we
created our own business rules based on
the tech and business priorities for
example a project that has on-premise
connectivity or a project that has data
classification labels of PCI PII all the
recommendations for that project will be
marked with higher priority the second
is access type access type is based on
the number of permissions and whether
the type of access is edit and delete it
will have higher priority then say a
view only role the third step is
remedied the remediation could either be
create a ticket for the partner team in
which case we'll create a JIRA ticket or
it would be auto applying the
recommendation which is an automated way
that the pipeline kicks in and Auto
remediates so now let's look into the
detail architecture we wanted to make
the architecture server less and
event-driven based on cloud functions
and pub/sub so as to make it scalable
and extensible to future use cases the
first step is to get the recommendations
we spoke about how the manager which is
a cloud function and before I delve into
the detail we thought about this server
less event-driven architecture based on
cloud functions and pub/sub so as to
make it scalable and
principle for future use cases so our
manager which is a cloud function runs
periodically in our case on a daily
basis cause I'm recommender API fetches
the recommendations and stores it in a
fast or DB the reason we chose fire
stole is because it's easy to use and we
needed a no sequel solution barring the
extensibility of the schema in mind so
then the second flow is we're using data
transfer jobs we get recommendations
from I'm recommender and store it into
the bigquery bigquery allows us to have
a single pane of glass where we could
see all the permissions across over on
the second component in the first step
is enricher it has two main functions
it gets project details from resource
manager and the project details could be
who's the owner of the project or what
was the create time of the project and
the second details it gets is from Jace
wait and it gets details about the
active employees in the company right
now this is needed for the orphaned use
case all these details are stored in
files to DB then step two is where the
manager invokes an action via pub/sub
what is the action doing the action
reads the recommendation and determines
what is the next step or what is the
right remediation to apply to that
recommendation it also decides what is
the priority and the risk code so that
is where we do prioritizing and
actioning on each recommendation in the
forest ODB once this is done we move on
to step three which is remedied so in
step three if it is a creator ticket
type of recommendation then the action
invokes an internal service the internal
service reads the details of the
recommendation from firestore DB and
creates a geological if it's an auto
apply type of recommendation then the
action invokes are a mediator
which is basically a cloud function and
the remediate er reads the details from
files to DB and it does then two steps
one it cause I am recommender to claim
the recommendation and second it calls
cloud I M to apply that recommendation
and market successful please note like
Abbie said before apply the entire
recommendation as a whole policy and not
just a specific rule binding now I would
love to show you how we have built it
this is the cloud console where our
project teams can go and see what are
the I'm roles and what are the
recommendations for example the first
one that you can see is a service
account for compute and it's been
assigned an editor roles and there is an
icon from I am recommender to suggest
there's a recommendation for it
next our step one has kicked in and the
manager calls
I'm recommender API to get payload about
the recommendations this is what a
typical payload looks like as you can
see there are two actions being
suggested one is to remove the role and
one is to add a role also note there is
an e tag which we use for concurrency
and versioning control each time there
is an update to a recommendation a new e
tag is generated now come step two this
is where the manager has simplified the
recommendation for internal use you can
very clearly see the action is to remove
the editor role and to add a smaller
data prop worker role and you can see
the action has also given a severity
which is medium and a risk or so we have
prioritized it now the action has
determined this particular case is for
create a ticket type remediation and
that's why a JIRA ticket is created this
is a sample ticket here but some things
to note the ticket is assigned to the
project owner in this case it is me
because I own the project we also
include a resource link so that project
owners can directly click on the link
and go to GCP console where they can see
the actual recommendation then we have
the description
where
we note why this ticket was generated
and how to go about fixing it with
detail screenshots and steps there is
also severity level or a priority level
coming to step 3 this is where a project
owner can go in the cloud console and
apply the remediation you can see from
our previous steps this is the same
service account for compute example the
recommendation is applied and now
instead of editor roll it has the data
prop worker role and there is no I am
recommend a sign of light bulb there so
lessons learned as with any product it
is important to spend time upfront in
understanding the api's and trust the
recommendations or trust the data our
technical design and approach came about
from the proof-of-concept we did right
in the beginning it was very easy to
apply or to apply all the
recommendations we got but then we found
that there were edge cases like backups
or break loss accounts where we needed
manual in dimension loading the
landscape we knew we had a problem with
over granted permissions but we did not
know how severe the problem was bigquery
and data transfer jobs help us get a
cross project overview across the orc
and understand our iron footprint
encouraged with a better understanding
of our iron status it solidified our
intent in going after our I'm axis and
using I am recommender and finally being
early adopters we got stuck at times
here we were able to leverage our
partnership with Google in terms of
technical expertise and product
assistance it was a great overall
learning experience and Google was an
awesome partner thank you thank you I'm
so happy to hear that and sharing your
story super excited about customers like
uber and thousands more who are using I
am recommend every day to minimize their
attack surface and achieve lease
privilege with least effort we
introduced this product last year at
next to provide AI for cloud governance
and since then we have launched several
new
and interesting features first we have
made policy utilization data more
readily accessible with I am insights
this lets you build custom reports or
integrate recommendations into your
governance tools second we now support
recommendation of multiple granular
rolls to help you migrate of legacy
roles like owner and editor next we have
expanded our analysis and
recommendations to groups so what we now
tell you for group is over provision and
what role to assign it
lastly we now recommend creation of
custom roles where if you find that a
custom role can be used across your
projects to reduce overground in your
access we take you through the steps of
creating that custom role and we have
many more features in developing that
our customers are pretty excited about
another area we have invested in is
making recommendations easier to
discover we felt as an area that needed
much more investment now project teams
can self-serve in the cloud console in
the iam page as you have seen already
and now they are also able to find
recommendations in a recommendation hub
that is located on the cloud console
dashboard here project teams can review
the insights and recommendations and
apply them if they have the permission
for central security teams we now
support out of the box
integration with bigquery with a few
simple steps you can export all your
recommendations to a bigquery table and
this will allow you to create all white
custom reports for example if you want a
view of over-provisioning across your
production workloads you can use our or
analyze permissions for a given service
account you cannot do this easily with
our analytical tools
lastly we expose insights and
recommendations through api's with
methods such as get claim mark has
succeeded so in addition to automating
recommendations as we heard hoover
described today some customers have uses
to create alerts and reminders such as
weekly digests that they send their
project teams to alert them they need to
take action we hope you've enjoyed this
deep dive into I am recommended today we
are excited to announce that recommender
is a power
of active assist a brand new solution
from Google cloud that we've just
announced active assist is a new
solution that focuses on reducing
complexity in your thought environment
by providing you with a variety of
intelligent and proactive features many
of them which are powered by machine
learning by using the capabilities with
an active assist you are empowered to
focus more of your time on your business
and less on cloud administration by
using the intelligent capabilities of
active assist it makes it really easy
and efficient for your teams to do their
jobs especially with things like finding
out what went wrong quickly so you can
take action right away with insightful
effective troubleshooting tools secondly
preventing mistakes from happening all
together by relying on analysis tools
before you commit to changes and lastly
as we saw today improving your cloud
easily with fast actionable
recommendations with clear rationales
for why
to get started with that to assist we
encourage you to visit the website and
go over to Clark in Seoul to the
recommendation hub and the I in page and
see if there any recommendations there
waiting for you some of the features we
highlighted are only available in
preview today but if you are interested
in getting early access to all of these
features as they get developed and give
us feedback we encourage you to join our
insider group
so which is linked on our website and
finally check out these other cloud
on-air sessions for deeper dive into
some of these features thank you for
your time we hope you enjoy the session
today and happy ironing